the very first memory I have of my
entire life where I start my life is me
laying on my bloody mom's body looking
up at my dad screaming at him you just
killed my
[Music]
mom hello everyone watching and
listening today I'm pleased to be
talking to Mr Aaron Stark you might
recognize him from his Ted Talk on
YouTube which has got about 13 million
views um Aaron went to some very dark
places when he was a kid and a teenager
and came from some very dark places uh
at one point in his life he had
formulated very detailed
plans that related to shooting up a
school and he decided not to do it and
what we're we're talking about what
we're going to talk about is how he came
to make those plans let's say what the
rationale for it was in the cause of
those plans and then also why he decided
to back away from the precipice and what
the consequence of that backing way has
been so Mr Stark you turned your life
around yes sir okay so let's go back to
when it wasn't turned around now you've
been touring around and talking to
people for how how long how long have
you been in the public eye um about 5
years about 5 years how old are you now
uh 44 okay and so well why don't you
just tell us the story and and and then
I'll start delving into well the details
well so I was almost a school shooter
when I was really young my I went
through a really violent aggressive
family my uh first five years or like
living in a Stephen King movie my birth
father was the most violent depra person
I've ever met um beatings and rapes and
just violence and aggression the entire
time running from him across state to
state trying to get away um when my mom
finally escaped him got with my stepdad
and went from Stephen King to Scarface
so it went from extreme violence to
crack cocaine and crime and you were
about six I was about five or six at the
time yeah um and I had an older brother
who's two years older than I was and so
we were very nomadic I went to 30 or 40
different schools I we were constantly
moving from state to state running away
from the cops or the um social workers
or counselors or anybody trying to
intervene and lived a very nomadic
lifestyle and went from early on being a
really shy sensitive sweet kid who liked
reading comic books and superheroes and
and that kind of stuff
to in my early teen years really
adapting that to the way to survive was
I'm going to be the aggressive one I I I
knew I I figured out early on that I was
the dirty one I was the nasty one I was
the worthless I was the outcast I was
the one that was pushed off early on
meaning when six 7 years old that I my
my older brother you were assuming it
was you oh yeah it was me um my older
brother was two years older than I was
because of my family Dynamic he had a
lot of responsibility he had to be an
ear the early man of the house really
early on to the extent where he had at
12 years old had to handle the um
Sheriff throwing all of our stuff in the
front Yan and evicting us while my
parents are getting drugged out and
drunk at the bar and we can't find him
for days and he has to find us a place
to stay and I was the responsibility how
much older than you was he two years so
he was 12 I was 10 and so he was just
another kid going through abuse the same
way I was um but he had to he I was a
responsibility he had to take care of so
while he was shouldering all the
responsibility I'm like the burden and
so that was kind of the identities we
adapted he was the one that took care of
everything I was the one that was the
broken thing that needed to be taken
care of all the time and as That Grew
Older I I became more and more toxic
going into my early why do you think
there wasn't enough responsibility also
for you like why did the why do you
think the rules between you and your
brother had to be split that way I don't
know if they had to be but that's just
kind of the way they ended up being I I
the um he just because of our
personalities he was more of a Hands-On
kid he he well he he like he was a
Gearhead too his his likes were more
were more physical he liked doing things
like building things taking stuff apart
fixing cars stuff like that I was more
intellectual I liked reading and loved I
I would read like The Bu mythology
textbook when I was four or five years
old I my first book report was on
Stephen King's misery when I was in
kindergarten and because by I I read
really early on super early I was
reading I was reading full books by the
time I was 5 years old and the um so I
was I would suck in information so that
was my Escape my Escape when all the
crime and the violence and people
beating each other and digging through
crack rock for crack rock behind me was
going on I would have my nose dug into
an X-Men comic book my brother would be
into taking part of skateboard putting
the skateboard back together right so he
was more oriented doing practical things
World practical things in the world and
so when as that gal he was the one that
had to do like well the car is broken
Jake's gonna try to fix it the this this
thing's busted Jake's gonna fix it I
didn't fix anything I was off to the
side reading a book I was out like I
wasn't I was more practically
oriented I wasn't utilitarian to to
anything I okay so you said you were a
sweet kid but that things started to
change well maybe about when you were 10
if I got that right oh earlier I'd say 7
8 n yeah I I because of the way that we
moved we were constantly moving from
Colorado to Oregon back and forth and
this was the late 80s so it was before
the age of the internet was really easy
to make up your entire personality and
make up a whole new identity so my
parents would get a job in a house out
here in Colorado and then get evicted
lose their job move to Oregon lie about
their entire resume lie about their
entire history get an entire new house
and everything and then wash repeat
every couple of months right right and
so we were always moving back and forth
and and they were doing that so that
their scams could continue it was either
their scams could continue or they would
evade U um accountability they were
trying to so that sort of behavior is
Gen generally rarer among women you said
your birth father was a particularly
nasty piece of work yes and so did you
have did you have any sort of quality
relationship with your mother or your
father at that time yes early with with
my father Yes my mom at that time was
much more like Linda Hamilton from T2
okay I don't from Terminator she was the
survivalist mother who like to the point
where when my my father was so violent
and chasing us around we were bouncing
from batter woman shelter to batter
woman shelter to get away from him and
my mom would have things like um safety
words so if we were out about if she
just said the word pocket in
conversation that was a safety tag so
she could be at the grocery store like
oh 2.95 here we go pocket if that word
came out of her mouth I was to grab grab
the back pocket of her pants and we need
to get out right now that me my father
was in insight there was trouble we need
to go now we need to move and so it was
that kind of survivalist and that was
the first five years first five years of
so why do you think your mother stayed
with your father during that fiveyear
period during that fiveyear period I
think that from my stories that I heard
he was a Vietnam vet and when I was when
he left to go to the war he was a good
guy when he came back he was kind of a
monster oh yeah and so that was I guess
was she with him before he went to
Vietnam was she already established a
Rel already established a relation with
damaged by was then damaged by the war
came back and was completely a monster
and was just violent got into um he
was epically violent what was he hurt
physically do you know during the war he
he wasn't hurt physically during the War
I don't think I know he was hurt
psychologically during the war he do you
know why do you know what happened he
was a gunner on a ship he was one of the
ones that would load the the bomb the um
ammunition to shoot up off into Cambodia
and he was on the the ship and one of
his best friends got his head taken off
right next to him just the ammunition
was blw as for best friend away right
next to him and that messed him up but
that wasn't that pales in comparison to
the trauma he suffered from his family
my father from his own family was
circumcised at 15 years old okay so what
does that mean exactly he they they
circumcised him they cut off the forkin
of his penis at 15 years old because
they caught him masturbating I see so
that that's the just an example of the
abuse that my father went through so
that's abuse in my opinion is
generational it's trauma that rolls
downhill and that both from both sides
in my family there were giant Boulders
of trauma that were rolling downhill
from my father's side there was that
from my mother's side I had a pedophile
great-grandfather a pedophile Uncle
rapist that there was a lot of violence
and aggression on both sides and lot
alism lots of alcoholism mental
disorders lots of a lot of personality
disorders a lot of drug abuse
yeah yeah well patterns of behavior are
imitated right consciously and
unconsciously and what that means is
that if there is a pattern of pathology
in a family it will echo down the
generations until someone digs into the
underbelly of the problem sorts it out
and stops it and then at least in
principle that'll stop the
intergenerational transmission there are
genetic predispositions but complex a so
you can have a genetic predisposition to
depression which would mean that you're
likely to be higher in the trait
neuroticism which is a trait associated
with negative emotion there are also
heritable Tendencies towards antisocial
personality so if you're extroverted and
disagreeable and even worse if you're
extroverted disagreeable and
unconscientious if you take a
pathological turn you'll tilt likely in
a criminal Direction and some of that
has a heritable element too it doesn't
mean that wrongdoing or the proclivity
for criminal behavior is heritable
precisely it means that we inherit
different patterns of traits that
predispose us to different categories of
Temptation you might say right yeah the
way I present it to my family is that we
are taught different languages of how to
express our different our emotions and
if if if your vocabulary of of emotional
expression is violence and aggression
then that's the language you're going to
teach everybody else yeah well Al means
that you don't know the Alternatives
precisely and and so it's it's really
hard to express yourself in a Comm
rational manner if only the only
language you speak in your head and
outside and in your world is violence
aggression and toxicity it's really hard
then to yeah well it's also difficult
for people who are temperamentally more
aggressive to learn how to integrate
that aggression in a socialized manner
so if you have a small child who's
extroverted and disagreeable they're
going to push you and they're going to
test constantly now if you take a firm
Tack and you're
sophisticated you can help those
children become socialized and
competitive in which case their
proclivity to push can be well usefully
channeled into you know competitive
Victory let's say but it's hard to do
that especially when the kid if the
kid's particularly pushy and I I see
that privity to push actually manifests
itself in a large scale from my
estimation from what I've seen doing
what I do um in kids who are in that
dark place that are in that gray area of
depression that might fall into the dark
even further that are trying to reach
out for help the people that reach out
to help too they're going to test
they're going to push they're going to
see are you Funk are you are you are you
are you lying to me like everybody else
in my life said they were here for me
and then they disappeared when
everything got heart and so they're
going to really test and test and test
until you prove consistency and so that
that proclivity to test could if if you
don't address that early on that it just
sprouts and grows GNA be exacerbated
betrayal yeah it turns into a main um
defense mechanism and and lifestyle that
that you're going to you're going to
push and be aggressive to everybody
until you can see that one person that
actually can stand there yeah well
people can people who have been betrayed
and
rejected sufficiently can get to the
point where they won't make a bond with
anyone right there there was there's
research conducted I can't remember the
people who did it on children who were
separated very young for too long from
their parents and they go through a
period of protest that's very intense to
begin with of course they're distressed
about being separated and then the
protest Behavior decreases but it'll
emerge sporadically and then that'll
decrease and once the protest Behavior
has been eradicated completely it's very
difficult even if the parent comes back
to reestablish contact the children put
up a barrier which is akin to the
barrier that you're describing that's
very difficult to pierce and as you said
what'll happen too to children who
abandon is that because they've been
betrayed repeatedly and deeply and hurt
very badly is they will test like mad to
see if they can break the bond to see if
it's reliable and it that can actually
get to the point you see this in
conditions like borderline personality
disorder where the person will test
everyone so completely that no one can
actually put up with it yeah ex and and
see that quite a lot and and I I think
that the more we can that that's the
advice that I give them when I get doing
my talks is that be that island of
normal in the ocean of chaos that person
that person is everybody when I was in
that spot everybody in my life thought
that I was either a monster or a project
you either wanted to fix me or you
afraid of me and if if neither one of
those were a person and so yeah well a
project is often some that people
undertake for their own self-
glorification precisely and and if I'm
if if I'm just a mark on your checklist
and and I'm not actually I'm an activity
to you I'm not I'm not a person you're
engaging with and a rational response
and listening to my and having a
rational reasonable discussion and
discourse I'm an activity on your
checklist and and that means that I'm
automatically under you when we have
activities and we're doing things that
activity is is a thing we are doing well
that's the toxicity of pity M the
toxicity of pity demoralizing reason it
is and the thing that my best friend did
and he's still my best friend to this
day was he was the one person that saved
my life by treating me like I was a
respectful person that deserved when did
you meet him I met him when I was 10
okay so did you have friends before
being before the age of 10
I not really I well it's hard with an
itinerant lifestyle yeah yeah I didn't
have any real connections and then even
after that once I once once they that
slightly stabilized in my teen years the
moving down slowed down a little bit was
able stay place for slightly longer I
didn't really gather friends I got what
I called disaster groupies they were
people that wanted to kind of live
vicariously through my darkness cuz they
didn't didn't really have anything like
me in their world so we were there was a
bunch was that like a group of outcasts
yeah it was a bunch of bunch of Team
kids yeah so well me and maybe one or
two others that had a similar kind of
background because there it was looking
back it was a bunch of depressed kids
trying to navigate depression without
any adult supervision but it was in in
reality what was going on was there was
a house that one of my friends at one of
my classmates at school his Dad paid the
rent his dad bought all the food but his
dad didn't live there so it was just my
16-year-old friend and his little
brother that stayed there and so that
turned into just
for a bunch of kids and so that was
everybody else there guance no guidance
whatsoever and so that that turned into
where all the other kids had houses and
had families and could go there they
were they were rebelling they were they
were they were trying to find their own
way these all the other kids all the
other kids in the group they were like
rebelling and stuff I didn't have a
house to go back to I was going to go
back sleep in the field behind cab
Bonita in Denver I was I was going to go
try to steal free samples out of the
grocery store and evade my criminal
family if I did if I did hit my family's
house it was to grab a couple little bit
of clothes so I could get out of there
before the violence started so I wasn't
I wasn't going home to any stability I
was going to go live on the streets and
I was going to go try to survive they
all got to go home to their houses and
so in that so you were in this right
like neck deep and they playing with it
just exactly exactly they they were they
were playing it with it I was living it
fully MH and that that kind of they were
like pushing me further off on the edge
it was like a real life Reddit for him
it was like were you getting rewarded so
to speak for your more the darker parts
of your personality yeah rewarded so to
speak in a social sense where it's it's
like it turns into like a party favor
almost like let me tell you the
craziness of what happened to my day
yeah you had a friend like that who was
extraordinarily comedic and and he was
he was probably the funniest person I've
ever met in my life and it got at one
point it got to be a burden to him
because that's what people expected they
expected him to be on and funny all
yes I've had that time where I'm at a
party and like oh up tell me what
craziness your family went through today
I'm like I don't want to talk about it
dude I got Cuts in my arms from it like
I don't want to talk about this pain
right now yeah but it it would turn into
the to the to the fiction but so when
we're talking about that that that leads
into the toxicity of what fed my own
anger toxicity and depression with going
into that spot because I by that point
when I that was I started doing that
when I was 14 years old okay what year
is this do so I was 14 years old I was
born in 1979 so we're talking 993 93
okay just to just to place it just to
place it and you're in Denver at this
point yep Denver and 14 14 years old and
that's when I finally left home because
I couldn't deal with the violence and
the crime and the beatings constantly
and watching my mom stab my uncle in the
gut with a doorknob if you take AP part
a doorknob the inside gear parts that
pointy yeah that makes a very dangerous
weapon don't ever stab someone with it
um and so just violence like that
constantly like like what does
constantly mean like living in that figh
ORF flight response every minute of
every day okay how often did you see
events that were violent in your house
three or four times daily and what kind
of violence to the point where here
here's an example I'm sitting in my
bedroom and I nobody had seen that I
came home from school or I think I was
working a day job I think I was 15 or 16
at the time I walked in sat down in my
bedroom nobody heard that I was home I
picked up the game controller was
playing PlayStation for a second heard a
rumble outside my bedroom and I stand
outside and my stepdad has my mom up
against the wall by her throat it's
dangling like threw two feet off the
ground and she's he's choking her and so
I immediately grab him I'm large my just
H hit puberty so I was big I was getting
into my body grabbed him slammed him
into the microwave broke the microwave
pushed him back slammed him into the
fridge broke the fridge pushed him back
into the back wall then I had him by his
throat up against the wall choking him
and now my mom is smashing plates over
the back of my head for me to drop him
she's she's attacking me because I got
into the fight so I drop him go back to
my video game pick up the game
controller keep on playing nothing
happen like go you go from Z to 60
instantly right right right and then go
back to nothing and do that four or five
times a day and in at the drop of a hat
stuff can go wrong and at the same time
dealing with my parents their method of
of discipline or any kind of control was
to threaten the absolute worst possible
thing right that's not I'm going beat
you terribly I'm I'm I'm going to beat
you terribly I'm going to kick you out
you're going to gone you're going to be
out of here immediately and then 5
minutes later act like nothing happened
they wouldn't follow through with any
kind of punishment but act like nothing
happened in that conversation at all and
we were just having a good
day diversify your savings with physical
precious metals while stockpiling silver
in your home safe with Birch gold
group's most popular special of the year
now through December 22nd for every
$5,000 you spend with Birch gold they'll
send you a 1o silver eagle coin for free
text Jordan to 9898 98 to claim your
eligibility now you can purchase gold
and silver and have it shipped directly
to your home or have Birch Gold's
precious metal specialist help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into a
tax sheltered Ira in gold for no money
out of pocket and once again they'll
send you free silver for every $55,000
you purchase keep it for yourself or
give something with real value as a
stocking stuffer this year just text the
keyword Jordan to 9898 98 to claim your
eligibility with an A+ rating with the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
happy customers now is the time to buy
gold from Birch gold text Jordan to 98
9898 and claim your eligibility for free
silver on qualifying purchases before
December 22nd that's Jordan to 98
[Music]
9898 and so were you ever disciplined in
a manner that you regard as vaguely
appropriate no no never and when I was
when I was a a kid they had lost the
ability to parent me by the time I was
12 I didn't they how are you going to
tell me to be home by 10:00 when you're
digging through the crack the carpet for
crack rock in front of me yeah because
they didn't think they didn't want to
hide anything so they did it all right
in front of me they would pull out the
the the flat iron why didn't they want
to hide anything that was just my mom's
philosophy she just didn't didn't
believe it hide that's like a warped
form of honesty she yeah she would pull
out the electric skillet with the water
and the vials and the baking soda and I
watched her Rock up crack right in front
of me I learned how to do it when I was
5 years old I took crack to school was a
SE and tell for one of my school that's
not generally a very good idea no it
isn't right but that would also indicate
how much you didn't know how strange
what was going on in your family
actually was and it was part of what
built into me that help was a Peril that
reaching out for help was a danger okay
that it was there because I when I would
do that when I would I took crack rock
to school and then the next day we're
out we moved out of state and so as as
another example I was really I I was
very unkempt very dirty very smelly I
wasn't i' never had had clean clothes I
never changed my my clothes I would
constantly be filthy and there was one
school I was I went to I must have been
9 10 years old or pre really young and I
went to the school and on the walk to
the school I actually defecated in my
pants and kept on going I crapped my
pants and kept on going to school and so
I walked went to school spent the entire
day there the next day I go to school
and there's a box of stuff for me okay
the teacher had brought a box of stuff
they brought clothes and books and coat
and all these new school supplies I take
it home and I show my mom like hey check
out I got all this stuff yeah the very
next day we're out we moved away because
that's the sign the teacher got too
close that someone's investigating too
fast and we need to go so I see it
turned into a danger signal that if I'm
if I'm if I reached out for help someone
attending to you if I reached out for
help that meant that the police might
get involved my parents might go to jail
my brother might go to foster care I
might go to foster care all because I
tried to get help right right so so okay
so let's go back to between 1 and 5 you
talked a little bit about your M your
dad you said your dad was particular to
Dam in Vietnam your mom had established
a relationship with him before he went
so I imagine she felt somewhat beholden
to him and also I would imagine maybe
she loved him certainly she would have
felt sorry for him when he came back
because he was so damaged and so how did
they how did the two of them spiral into
the trouble that they had and then when
did you and your brother come along like
they were they married they were married
they did get married they were married
by the time I was
born the extreme violence had already
started so I'm not sure about how that
spiraled in I have memories early on of
my father sleeping on the on the on the
couch and my mom realizing he's finally
asleep so she picked up a 2x4 and beat
him bloody beat him almost till he was
dead because she tried to escape and she
when so she beat him in how old do you
think you are I was four and you can
remember that mhm I remember him beating
I remember him laying on the couch and
her over him slamming into him with a
2x4 I remember that and then us going
and but then he found us and the okay
you left but he found you he found us
and and he would chase us down so there
was a there was a there's a distinct
memory I have of us in a Boman shelter
me and my mom and my older brother were
living in a batter woman shelter and me
and my brother playing outside okay and
a car pulls up and my dad kidnaps me and
my brother takes us kid convinces me
particularly to get into the car I'm
pretty sure my brother just followed us
I just get in the car CU it's my dad MH
and so he takes us and then calls the
batter woman shelter talks to my mom
tells my mom that one of us are dead and
the other one's going to be dead if she
he he she doesn't show up at this
restaurant to meet him okay and so she
against the protestations of the batter
woman shelter of course she goes there
to meet him at this restaurant and when
she gets there and I know I know the
story both from Vivid recounts from her
from the story and from news clippings
that we had growing up um so she gets to
the goes to the restaurant and he's
there and he pulls he they're arguing
and he flips the table over in the
argument pulls out his classic weapon
which was a cross-shaped x-shaped tire
iron that's was his that was weon Choice
oh yeah so he picked that up and went to
go hit her with it and right then
everybody else in the uh restaurant
pulled out guns and pointed at him
because the bad woman shoulder called
ahead and filled it with undercover
police officers and so I had had a news
clipping when I was a kid of my dad
getting LED out of a restaurant with
shotguns at his head are are your mom
and dad still alive my mother is my
father I don't know and my stepdad died
in 201 15 do you still see your mom no I
haven't spoken to her since I came out
with my story last time last time I
talked to my mom I was I had just left a
live TV show appear parents in Denver I
was having a really good moment I just
was on live TV for the first time took
my daughter with me she got to see a TV
studio so I was having a cool little how
many kids do you have four four kids how
old are they 23 20 16 and 12 the two
older my step 16's my and you're married
uh 13 years 13 years and how has your
marriage been great fantastic really
yeah congratulations I am as happy as
can be and I successfully broke the
cycle my family doesn't have any of the
trauma that I went through okay good
well we'll get into how you did that
okay so now back when you little your
mom and dad are in a very violent
relationship they're married your dad
obviously wants you guys around for some
reason like I think it was more to
control her I didn't think it have
anything to do with us CU once we were
gone he didn't care he he never he never
came he never came to contact I never
had any time where Dad tried to reach
out never had any of those loving
conversations I don't have any loving
memories with my father the very you had
no relation the very first memory I have
of my entire life where I start my life
is me laying on my bloody mom's body
looking up at my dad screaming at him
you just killed my mom oh yeah that's
where I start that's not a good that's
yeah Alfred Adler a famous psychologist
he he believed that those first memories
in some ways are determinative right
that they sort of set the frame and so
that's a hell of a first memory mhm yeah
yeah now you had your older brother did
you have a relationship with him I did
we were pretty close growing up okay so
you had a you had a male role model in
the house who wasn't completely
pathological do you see your brother I
haven't talken to him since I started
talking about it that side of the family
attacks me not because I'm saying
something that's not the truth but just
because I'm talking because I there and
your brother as well doesn't feel that
that's appropriate because I'm because
I'm making my mom
cry because I see and so he feels that's
inappropriate in relationship to your
mother does he still see your mother I
believe so yeah I don't know I haven't
spoken to any of them I haven't spoken
to that side of the family in five years
five years years okay so when you're
little how do you survive between one
and five like you have your brother so
that's definitely a plus okay and you
said that you were a very early reader
so so you escaped into the world of
fiction and reading yep so comic books
and you do well in school I so I tested
off the the charts in my tests did you
do any of my assignments I never well
that's not surprising yeah well first of
all that's not all that atypical for
smart kids but you lived in a pretty
chaotic environment so it would have
been quite surprising had you managed to
buckle down and do your work did you
pride yourself on your intellect I did I
did I I would carry around bullfinch's
mythology with me all the time or giant
stacks of X-Men comic books or the
complete works of Shakespeare and just
read viously and I love doing like oral
reports and book reports and when I was
in high school one at the final High
School North High in Denver the um only
two classes I ever actually attended
were English class and choir
class the I would I would skip every
other day and I and I even failed those
classes because of attendance rules once
you miss four days you failed the
semester oh yeah and I would only attend
class once every three weeks or so but
the classes I would go to were quite
English class in choir class why choir
choir because I think that actually has
a superpower when it comes to kids who
are depressed I did you sing I did I I
still do I still love singing um and I I
was in Statewide choir and Citywide
choir and 16 person Acappella choirs I
would always go whenever all the schools
I would go to I would go to whatever the
advanced choir was and try out for it
because that's that's what I wanted to
do what did they make of you in the
choir because you said you were like an
uncamp kid you you Dr badly you're dirty
the teachers always put me in I I when I
went to I went to Oregon one time and I
managed as a freshman in high school to
through a try out make it into the
senior Acappella choir that was just a
16 person AC capella choir only for
seniors and I was a freshman so you had
literature and music to save you yep
yeah did you listen to a lot of music I
did who were your favorites um I oh I
I'm very eclectic I like a wide range
back then it was I liked a lot of oldies
I liked I really liked the 50s music so
I listen to a lot of like buddy Hol
positive music yeah I listen to a lot of
like Buddy Holly and that kind of stuff
and the labomba soundtrack I play that a
lot um and then I didn't really like the
80s style music the poppy kind of stuff
I didn't really like that but I got into
metal when I was older so the 9 Inch
Nails downward spiral album is pretty
much an autobiography like that's that's
pretty much the how my life was going at
the time and so it was when I was a teen
it was 9inch Nails Marilyn Manson uh
panta tulle that kind of stuff right
right so the dark end of the metal
Spectrum but the more intelligent end of
the met I wasn't really into the death
metal screaming anger kind I was into
the stuff that was talking about the
emotions I liked I like singers that
have heart so like Credence clear water
revival yeah some some when you sing it
it feels like it's digging in your soul
yeah yeah yeah they're great their music
has aged very well tooed Clear Water
yeah yeah yeah so okay
so one to five you had no relationship
with your father except one that was
extremely negative all you saw from him
was violence you had some relationship
with your mother do you think your
mother loved you yeah yeah some of
that's where the only time I have good
memories with my mom is during that time
the best memory I have with my mom ever
is sitting watching willly Wonka's
chocolate factory and singing every
single song and we knew I I knew every
word to that movie so I would sit there
and sing the entire movie and we would
go back and forth with the songs and
that was the best memory of my childhood
that's that's the highlight of those
years and are you during that time 1 to
5 are you playing with any kids or are
you playing with your older brother you
remember any play no no no not really
any play just just reading I wasn't much
of a player everybody else would go out
and play and I'd sit with my CLE with my
books oh so okay so you were you were
now let me ask you some questions about
your personality if you don't okay
introverted or extroverted then or
now that's changed eh mhm were you
introverted be before or were you just
you just afraid of people that's a good
question I I I don't think I was afraid
of people people think I was well back
then I was because it took a while for
me to burn that out of myself I when I
in my teen years I think that I lost the
ability to get embarrassed or ashamed or
afraid of anybody because when I was a
kid I made fun of myself more than
anybody else did very self-deprecating
yeah that's good trick I had a better
fat joke than you did better insult than
you did and so yeah it would be
surprising to me if you were introverted
as a kid because you appear to be very
extroverted you smile a lot you talk
quickly I don't think that it would I
don't think introverted would have fit
but I don't I wasn't extroverted
I was I would I kept to myself pretty
much but I liked the Arts so okay so
maybe what happened was that your
interest in literature let's say in the
Arts was so strong that if you had to
choose between being with people and
reading you picked reading yes yes
because I always wanted to learn more
stuff I I wanted I I like to I I I even
now I'll be walking listening to I just
finished uh um Lawrence krauss's book
edge of knowledge which so like bleeding
edge pH physics and Science and
philosophy your podcasts and I listen to
I listen to a wide range of topics and I
try to I try to get the entire spectrum
of of opinions so I'll listen to the
farthest right the farthest left someone
in the middle all all different sides of
the topics and try to try to see the the
whole side of it and yeah so these days
I'm just I'm all over with it but I I
don't think that back then I was
introvert I think you might have hit the
nail and well very open tentative people
okay um are you compassionate polite or
tough and and and stubborn yes which one
yeah if you had to pick um so in general
I would think I'm compassionate and
polite however it because of the the
survival mechanisms and the the way I
had to live a long time I can turn on
that hard note pretty easily where I I I
can easily cut people out of my life I
can easily decide that you that it's
done and you are you're hurting me more
than you're good and I've given up My
Philosophy these days they give up too
much time of my life to people that hurt
me so I just don't do it anymore and so
I these days are you likely to be taken
advantage of or not no not now not now
not now before I don't think so but I
can't say no because I might have been
yeah okay I I you said when you were in
school you never did your assignments
now there are obviously situational
reasons for that are you are you a
conscientious person dutiful orderly
industrious or more easy going kind of
half and half I I tend to
go my wife is the one that does all the
planning so that's the best way to put
it when I'm when when I'm doing my
events and stuff my wife sets up the the
planning makees sure I have my she'll do
theing she'll do the scheduling I handle
the the material of it yeah and the um
I'm order detailed about certain things
but I'm very non-materialistic very very
non-materialistic nothing in my world
matters physically it's all about
experiences and it's all about memories
so like i' I've had at more than five
times in my life I had people burst in
my bedroom at 3:00 in the morning with a
duffel bag screaming at me we have five
minutes to get out of here we need to
grab everything and go and so everything
I had disappeared because the only thing
I would grab had time to grab is comic
books so I would lose all the toys I had
or all the TV I had or all the different
books I had I'd lose everything except
for my comic books and so over the years
nothing none of the material stuff
matters to me m and so it's really hard
for to buy me like my my my wife says
I'm the hardest person to buy a
Christmas present for cuz I don't want
anything to to give me the things that I
want yeah that's about
it yeah but a memory take me out on a
trip give me a memory give me something
fun right so you're very high in
openness right creativity interest in
ideas and interest in aesthetic
experience yeah so learning right and
that was one of the things that seems to
have saved you that you could that you
you found that Niche and that was
something you could do alone and you
could even do that that when you were
moving from place to place yep and it
was and it was a deep Escape so I there
could be abject violence happening right
next to me and I could be buried reading
about what happened with Mike crawler
and the Xmen you ever watched the
documentary crumb yep I love crumb
Albert crumb yeah yeah or Robert Robert
Crum well crumb you know what Crum did
reminds me a bit of what you did because
he took refuge in his R and that really
saved him you know he had life he had a
wife he had a child he had a career I
mean Jesus he's got a dark side that gu
and is he came from one brutal family
man it's rough so but he had that
creative Escape that sounds like it was
there for you okay so we covered a bit
of of your life from 1 to five and you
you talked about things starting to turn
on you around eight something like that
so yeah so well that's when we got so
the there's three steps in that right to
from 5 to 7 there's a there's like three
steps that happen because my the way my
my mom did it is she escaped My Father
by sending me I don't I don't know how
she actually got wi of him because we
went to Oregon she sent me and my
brother to Oregon for a year and by
ourselves just flew us out to Oregon to
go live with grandparents with grand oh
and did you have a relationship with
your grandparents with my grandmother
yes but that was the one of the most
toxic times of my life in that year of
Oregon because that sent me out to go
live with my pedophile rapist Uncle
that's right during that time so so
there was no Escape dur no escaping that
and that's that's when I figured out
that that trauma Hill is huge in my
family that there's a large mountain of
abuse like my grandfather his name is HL
because that's the only two letters that
his mom knew how to write when he was
born because she gave birth at 13 in the
Ozarks so she that that trauma Hill is
big and that they that so it wasn't
positive at all and so when we finally
came back from that after a year of that
my mom brought us back and she had got
with my stepdad and my stepdad was a did
she divorce your father I I think I I
don't I don't know I think she but she's
with another guy this is now your
stepdad yep yep and so um he is a smooth
talking criminal he is a a manipulating
lying oh smooth talking can selling ice
to an esimo kind of guy he's the kind of
guy that that will lie and steal every
day all the time right right and but
also gets heavily involved into drinking
when I met him he was in prison for
strong arm robbery he spent four years
in prison for strong round robbery he
would steal entire delivery trucks that
were going to to grocery stores and take
all the stuff and go sell it at the flea
market so why do you think your mother
picked him and do you know how they met
I mean she's already hanging around in
the dark side of the planet so I I
imagine she had the opportunity to run
into people like him I I think they met
at a bar and I think when they met at a
bar he heard about my father and was
like oh yeah I'll keep him away and it
turned it was started as a protective
thing I see so she found one monster to
keep another one at Bay yep aha do you
think that he was a project for her or
an adventure or no no you you think the
protection thing was genuine I think I
think the protection thing was genuine
at first and then it turned into a
trauma bond from all the the uh drugs so
he might have you said he was a
narcissistic manipulator he offered her
an escape that was false yes yes right
and okay and she stayed with him for how
long until he died he died in 2017 in
the most 16 or 17 the most fitting way
possible that that drunken drugged out
violence never stopped in my family and
they were having an argument while they
were high and drunk and he went to the
bathroom had an aneurysm collapsed in
the floor and crapped all over himself
laid there for three hours while she
screamed at him from the living room how
worthless he was I really can't think of
a more fitting way for the guy to
end that's why did she stay with him why
did she stay with him yeah you think she
thought she could she had she had severe
lack of of um self-respect and sense of
self- accomplishment she didn't think
she could do it she didn't think she
could survive without him she thought
that she was broken and couldn't do
anything without her she the and and he
over the years had kind of built that
into her right right and I see just she
just thought that he was indispensable
and she couldn't do anything without him
and so we we tried me and my brother me
and my brother tried to have
interventions I personally had an
intervention with him by by the age of
14 15 years old I'm big in beating him
up now because like I said I was I was
on from home I was living on the streets
but I was home occasionally because I
had to come home to recharge okay so
when were you with your grandparents 1
that was no I was with my grandparents
from 5 to six oh so okay five to six and
then so F first to five father one year
with my grandfather and then back home
with my with my stepdad with your
stepdad and then it was my stepdad on
and when did you get
big 13 years old oh how big 6 foot 280
lb oh yeah oh yeah so that was handy
I got big fast and right right but I was
also quiet shy and sensitive and didn't
know how to use it at the time so I got
picked on constantly I get used to get
go go to school and get bullied all the
time I would get beaten at school come
home with bruises all over me and I
never defended myself I would never
stand up for myself why why why why
didn't you defend yourself I I don't
know I I started defending myself one
day when I snapped and a kid had slammed
my head into a locker and I picked him
up and kind of ragd dolled him and
slammed him a bunch of times and I
noticed when I did that after that for
the next four or five months I was at
the school I didn't have anybody B right
right so that was the first time you
realized that eh why do you think it
happened then and hadn't happened before
despite the fact that you were bullied I
don't know I don't know I don't know I I
think that I think it might have been
because the chaos at home was really
starting to spin up the that's that's
right about the same time hit your limit
you know have you ever read about people
going berserk some yeah yeah yeah well
it often happens to people people who
are in a very chaotic environment who
are being abused continually and they
hit their threshold and it's something
like a last ditch Do or Die response
right it's like well I've tried to
retreat that's not working I'm cornered
I've got nothing to lose it's a very
dangerous position to put someone
in with the holiday season approaching
why not include saving a baby's life on
your Christmas list through our
partnership with pre-born an organ
gation that's rescued over 270,000
babies you can do just that every day
pre-born network of clinics rescues 200
babies as they compete head-to-head with
the abortion Giants you see they offer
an
[Music]
abortion-inducing
and more and now through a match your
tax deductible gift is doubled too for
up to 2 years you are offering double
blessings now is the time to put your
year-end write-offs to work have your
donation matched by dialing pound 250
and saying the keyword baby that's pound
250 baby or donate securely at preborn
docomo that's preborn doccom
[Music]
Jordan and that's that's where I ended
up being at the end of the story yeah I
bet okay so at 13 you're fairly large
and you learned one day at school that
if you so that happened when I was about
eight or nine when I when I ragged all
that kid CU I I was I was still pretty
big I was by that that was when I was
about was five and a half foot tall and
still pretty large I was growing into my
body at that point right so I was still
pretty big but that was when I first
figured out that that if I lashed out
the people would leave me alone I also
right around that same time figured out
that one of the first things it's I kind
of do the reverse of what people talk
about when they're going to prison you
know when they talk about going to
prison they think they're going to up to
the biggest guy and try to fight him and
then establish a role in the I would
kind of do the opposite I go up to the
biggest the most popular kid and then
insult myself to him and then and make
fun of myself to that kid uhhuh and kind
of like establish the pecking order
immediately like I go find the the
biggest the whoever the the ring leader
you did it with humor yeah well kind of
self deating humor that nobody else
found funny but me that kind of
insulting kind of like I see so you go
got the pecking order problem over with
as fast as you Poss fast as possibly
could and you you were willing at that
point to accept a relatively low social
position I knew I was by that point I
had I had internalized that I was the
low social I see I see so you thought
you might as well just get it over with
quickly yeah yeah I'm I'm going to end
up well then you don't have the conflict
yeah exactly the sooner I can resolve it
the less fight right right right
definitely the less bullying I'm going
to go through if I can if I can
establish myself right there and make it
and if I can do that and make fun of
myself I'm not an appealing Target
cuz bullies only want to go after you if
if you get a response out of you and
they can make you cry so did that
generally mean that you were left alone
even though you were at low man on the
totem pool kind of but it was more left
alone at a stabilized level of
ridicule okay like like left alone down
here yeah you know what I mean like like
it's it's not not left alone entirely
like hands off he's okay we can't make
fun of him anymore it's like we're going
to make him fun of him right here but
we're not going to pick on him down
there cuz it's not he's not going to cry
there's no there's no fun in that right
so it's predictable low stat predictable
predictable low status yeah that's a
good one yeah well you see this you see
that in in primate social troops too is
that sometimes this is one indication of
that is sometimes if an interloper comes
in who Could disrupt the whole hierarchy
you might think that that would be
useful for the lower ranking primates
because they would have an opportunity
to move up but they'll generally resist
the internal per two because the cost of
social transition the conflict that goes
along with social transition the cost of
that can be so high that they would
rather settle for the stable low status
than the unpredictable transition yes
that's that's a precise that that's a
very AP description of what was going on
with that I I would rather just be what
I think I am I'm the worthless one I'm
the one you're going to make fun of
anyway I'm the fat smelly one let's get
this out of the way and then I can go
ahead and try to live try to be I'm
going to be out of here less than six
months anyway cuz I'm pretty sure my
family's going to evaporate soon anyway
right so it's temporary so let's just
get this out of the way and we'll go and
while you're doing that you're sving
yourself so to speak with books and so
forth yeah right yeah right have life
and right around then that's when I
really started to get more and more
toxic and I really started to to between
between 9 and 13 was really when I
started to to become
more I not toxic in the in in a um
attacking way not like insulting
everybody I'm around just unappealing
and and and filthy and off-putting and
and and just just like kind of like give
off almost a xenophobic reaction like
like kind of like just don't want to
touch it kind of thing were you bitter I
think I think looking back yeah I think
I was well you had reason to be I mean
it would be surprising you I didn't
think I was then what did you think then
I think I was just living I I I didn't
have I didn't think that there was a
tomorrow then I would regularly say that
I felt my life was like I was watching a
movie like I was like I'm sitting in the
audience watching my movie pass by and
it sucks and I don't have any real
control over it like I well another
description I would use is like I'm
living in a tsunami of pain like I'm
just slashing back and forth like I
don't my feet are on First Response
that's called derealization it's a
symptom of trauma which is to see your
existence as separate from you right and
the Der realization is that this isn't
and I don't know if this accurately sums
up what you're you're saying but that
this isn't real right you you're like a
watcher yeah yeah it was felt very
unreal it it felt very much like I am
not in my movie I'm sitting in the
audience and my movie is passing me by
and every now and then it pulls me into
a scene and I have to be in it but I'm
not I'm not I don't have any script in
this I'm not engaged in this at all well
well yeah well that would also be
reflective at least in part of the fact
that you had almost no agency yeah right
I mean you're being pulled from place to
place it's not surprising that you felt
that things around you were going on
despite you because they were yeah right
so and that's a very difficult thing to
contend with when you're like nine yeah
yeah and and my brother at the same time
is getting a little more family status
because he is assuming the
responsibility he's the one that's
handling getting the houses when we're
getting evicted and he's the one that's
handling the fixing the car and he's and
he's also joining in so he starts doing
drugs with my family and he starts
drinking with them he's really early on
he just joins in so I don't I don't at
all I didn't why not I just I found it
very unappealing found I I I would sit
and watch those guys do it and I just
was I never understood why you would sit
there did you drink I not until I was in
my 20s oh is that well that was that was
a wise choice because you would have
been in real trouble especially if you
only drug I did as a teenager was LSD
uhuh I tripped LSD when I was 16 years
old but I didn't I didn't smoke weed
till I was
19 uh-huh yeah uh-huh okay so now you're
starting to change somewhat dramatically
around 8 you said you start to become
markedly consciously unappealing like
trying to turn people off do you think
but it started unconscious and then grad
and not I wouldn't even say gradually it
moved into conscious yes okay and what
so what what were your conscious
strategies and thoughts at that time I
wouldn't bathe I wouldn't change my
clothes I wouldn't I would I I wouldn't
brush my teeth I would say the really
inappropriate things about myself and
about what was going on I would describe
the stuff I was seeing in my house like
blatantly around people and it
was the just trying to
be and I think it was again trying to
establish that social pecking order on a
constant basis well it's also an attempt
it looks like an attempt also to bring
what was happening to you anyways some
degree of voluntary control right you
didn't there wasn't any obvious way for
you to improve it but one way to control
it was to take well you might think to
take ownership of it and what I don't
know what that is though to make it even
worse you know because in some ways
you're spiting yourself well people will
do that they'll punish themselves for
being low status for example yeah yeah
so yeah and and I knew that I belonged
there and I and I really internalized
that and the right so then you're worth
taking care of either no I wasn't worth
taking care of at all and and the at the
same time the violence and Chaos at home
is getting worse and worse like that's
they are now entering late stage crack
addiction and massive problems with
alcoholism and the the degradation of
the when you're an early drug addict
it's all right because your body might
be able to do it when you're 15 years in
you're you're not as resilient in it it
well you could imagine you could imagine
you had a choice to make imagine this is
the choice it's something
like either there's something wrong with
you and that's why what's happening to
you makes sense or there's something
unbelievably wrong with almost everyone
in your family that goes back multiple
Generations that's so deep that it's
terrifying and that's the decision that
I made the that's that's what I mean
when I say I changed because that's the
decision that flipped I went from
thinking that it was me to realizing
that it was
that between
19 and 27 so that was that was that was
what switched on you okay now you you've
talked publicly quite a bit about
violent the violent school shooter
fantasies okay so detail that out to me
do it chronologically so I can
understand and and the philosophy as
well cuz you're smart so the probability
that you had a philosophy is very high
so I'd like to know all of that so the
um the well we'll start around theat 14
years old age when I'm living with that
dis house when every all the teenagers
are there cuz that's right around when
that starts now you've got a gang kind
of yeah we'll call it a gang that's a
way to put it um and so i' I've got I've
got enablers let's say psychological
enablers with that and so I am I've now
fully embraced that I'm the dirty fat
one I like worn WRA the darkness around
like a blanket and it's it's it's become
my personality and now I the I started
self Haring right around 14 years old
what were you doing cutting I would
start with light cuts on my arms and it
started I think as an emotional
regulatory thing when it would calm the
tsunami it would it would when when I
felt like I was completely out of
control and that you yeah so let me ask
you something about that CU I've
wondered about that I've had clients who
self hared I'm wondering tell me what
you think of this hypothesis so imagine
know that time you snapped so you could
say you're out for blood mhm Okay so
imagine that there's a part of your
brain a relatively primordial part
associated with defensive
aggression which if pushed will only be
satisfied with the sight of blood well
so because it's many it's very common
that people who self harm will state
very specifically that unless they draw
blood they won't re they won't calm down
yeah no that's it's it's that's that the
because it wasn't finished if you don't
if you didn't draw blood you didn't do
it and and that was that was very much
it started with sacrificial gesture
right to offer blood up to the gods of
emotional storm in a way yeah and it
would and and emotional storm is a good
way to put it because it would really it
would calm the tsunami it would like
lower the thing it would maybe even not
lower it would kind of like cut through
that that fuzz with something that was
Concrete in mind and even though I knew
it was destructive and I knew doing it
it was bad and it was hurting me it was
still mine and it was real and nothing
else in my life felt like it was real
and so that that blood is real yeah yeah
and the scars afterwards are real and
the pain was real and the the cuts out
the the the scabs were real and all of
so that's interesting too because it
that means that it also stood as an
antithesis perhaps to that sense of
derealization that you had yeah and and
I was also at that time feeling a a
strong sense of of anger at a complete
lack of accountability for anybody in my
world nobody in my world had any
accountability or responsibility for
anything when stuff went wrong they
didn't have to deal with it they
evaporated and started over they they
didn't have to deal with the
ramifications of the hell they were
causing they just continued and
continued and continued why do you
suppose that bothered you and not them I
don't know that I don't know I it really
it really did start to bother me though
that was a thing that was really getting
to so that's a violation yeah yeah well
I can understand that you know compl
lack of of counter yeah when I see
people in in my life in various
places failing to be held accountable
for their pathological actions it's I
find that very very difficult especially
when there's no not even any self reli
not like not self- reliability self-
acknowledgement not even any
self-awareness that this is what's going
on it's like a VI to me it's a violation
of the intrinsic moral order yes it's a
violation of our social contract the
that we are supposed to at least engage
in a r in a normal way where I'm
supposed to if you say you're going to
do something I can reasonably accept
that that's what you're going to do not
that you're lying to me and doing
something else entirely behind my back
and then getting away with and then
getting away with it and smiling and
doing it again and enjoying the fact
that happened reing over like I had to
sit and listen to them laugh about how
the the lies that they were doing and
how my stepdad was stealing he worked at
a he would lose jobs over and over again
because he would get a job steal
everything from the job and go sell it
and then lose the job again and I would
sit and laugh and listen to them Revel
about that and laugh about that stuff
and it just angry and so I'm now in this
yeah well everyone that uh everyone that
Psychopathic Thief robs is a fool that's
how they justify it well if you're so
stupid I can steal from you then you're
so stupid that you deserve it ex right
everyone's a Rube and everyone's a
Target and the person who's doing it is
smarter than everyone else and they now
take that phenomenon and imply that in
that Dynamic to a depressed kid if
you're depressed you deserve it because
you're the worthless one and you should
have deserved it yeah so so you're in a
weird situation there because on the one
hand you feel that strongly that people
should be held accountable for their
moral shortcomings but on the other hand
you've accepted your role somewhat
perversely as low status you've started
to in some way Revel in it a little well
you've adopted it voluntarily and you
said you were pushing it to its limit
you said you WRA the darkness around it
it became a a a definite not only
personality trait but survival technique
right well it's an identity as well
worked in this in this house that you
were in it was I I was the dark unicorn
house where where they didn't have
anything like me but at the same time I
was living three parallel lives at that
exact moment okay cuz at that house dark
unicorn where all the pain I was going
through turned into a party favor it
turned into some weird positive in a
negative way yeah like negative positive
toxicity yeah I've actually seen people
like that and and so there there's that
side then I have my home life where it's
just abject hell and I'm the worst and
I'm the bottom and I'm the cast off and
I shouldn't even be there in the first
place why the hell am even in the house
then I have the other side which is I
met at at 12 years old which is Mike and
when I went to Mike's house Mike I so
it's a very important character to bring
him in the story right now so I met Mike
when I was he was 10 I was 12 we met at
a comic shop we bonded over comic books
we we met we played we met playing the
original Mortal Kombat 1 video game to
time it out to see where what time it
was um but we immediately bonded the
first day we met immediately hooked we
went I went to his house and basically
never left we just deep conversation I
was 12 he was 10 oh yeah and so we just
hooked up and I just basically never
left his house for a week why did his
parents put up with you they were really
at the time they were super sweet there
they have lived in a giant four-story
house they're both really well off his
dad was a computer programmer his mom
was a lawyer very very well to do um he
was he was just they thought that I was
just a sweet kid down the street I lived
at the opposite end of the one of the
blocks at that time so at the opposite
of the block at one of the houses I
lived in is what I meant and so we just
bonded immediately became good friends
and it started where we were I would
stay there for weeks and his parents
were fine with it and then over the
years stay there for a couple days and
they were okay with it by the time I'm
15 16 years old I can't stay there
anymore because now I'm really dirty and
filthy and if I sit on their couch they
have to clean it when I I see so you're
I see so you weren't so bad at the
beginning MH I okay I was wondering why
they would put up with you but I get the
picture now so you were a more or less
ordinary kid as far as they were
concerned when when the relationship
that was just his kid his son's friend
at the at the start and I was having a
rough life so they were going to try to
give me all and then over the years as I
went from 12 to to 13 14 15 that Arc
that abusive Arc I was going on made me
go down and made that and what's Mike
doing during the time that you're
declining he the whole time I've been
friends with Mike he's never treated me
like anything but an equal Mike did Mike
would tell me constantly you're a good
kid can I language in this podcast you
say whatever you want you're a good kid
in a world he would say over and
over you're a good kid in a world
and he that was like a constant refrain
he would tell me all the time and over
at his house and we would he we he would
listen to me about my pain I was in
listen to all the abuse and it was right
around that time with this when the self
harm started he would notice that I
would come in with cuts and he wouldn't
really ask but he would just like dude
you're going to be okay he would try to
tell me that and but I'm also spinning
out because I'm only there for a couple
hours and I go out and my world is very
chaotic I'm living so the normal part of
your the normal part of world is
shrinking very shrinking very quickly
okay and so I'm the self harm starts
getting really bad like deeper deeper
cuts and I can't stay at Mike's house
because his parents won't let me they're
they're I'm too filthy and I'm burning
out the rest of the friendship and then
that disaster groupy friends house ends
in one incident where I'm having a big
party there's like 20 kids there and all
these kids from the school and there's
even a band from one of the kids at the
house at that house we had the big big
party and then right in the middle of it
there like 13 kids tripping acid the
parents arrive so part's over all the
kids have to go home all the other kids
get to go home I get to go sleep in the
field by Ina Bonita because that's the
one last Refuge the spot where if I
could didn't have anywhere else to be if
I couldn't go to Mike's house behind
kasab Bonita which is a big Mexican
restaurant in Denver that if you ever
watch the show South Park did that whole
episode on kasab Bonita it's a big and
that episode's actually accurate it's
got pink restaurant with its cliff
divers it's really weird but behind
there there was a field and in the field
there was a little dip so if you laid in
you couldn't see it from the street so I
was kind of invisible little camping
area and so that was one of the last
places that I could be and so I they
about to go home I got to go there and
so when that happened that really sent
me off on a really dark spin where that
was kind of like my last support that I
had been staying at cuz I couldn't go
home cuz the violence at home was really
bad at that time like they were they
were in the midst of a crack binge for
months they were really really bad so I
couldn't go home at all for more than an
hour right and so I'm now homeless and
yeah right and you don't have mic I
don't have m point either no and by this
point instead of sleeping in his house
the only place I can go he lets me sneak
into his Tool Shed M because in his Tool
Shed behind his house they were they had
a big recliner chair they had in storage
like a big Lazy Boy and so I would go in
there and if I didn't have anywhere else
to be I could go to his toolshed and I
could sleep because do you still know
Mike he's still my best friend I just
talked to him yesterday oh wow still my
best friend in this world well thank God
for these small
mercies let me ask you this question are
you a peace with the Mindless screen
time you spend on your phone every day
are you gaining that higher quality of
life you know you desire if this sounds
familiar I have good news starting on
January 1st tens of thousands of men all
over the world will start 2024 with a
90-day journey together in search of a
more purposeful life it's called Exodus
90 and it was built to help men enjoy
the freedom of becoming who they were
truly made to be Exodus 90 guides you in
removing the attachments that are
holding you back from a better life and
it actually works independent research
shows that Exodus 90 men report
considerable shifts after the 90 days a
dramatic decrease in time spent on their
phon stronger satisfaction rates in
their marriages a more meaningful
relationship with God and true
brotherhoods of men on the same path for
the past 8 years Exodus 90 has helped
more than 100,000 men build their own
road map for living with virtue in a
culture that offers far too many paths
to self-destruction so is it time for
your Exodus we start January 1st find
resources to prepare for Exodus 90 at
Exodus 90.com Jordan that's Exodus
90.com Jordan to start your
journey um so I'm in his shed and now
I'm cutting myself so bad that there's a
pool of blood on the ground beneath me
and it's like 2:00 in the morning and I
look up and there's the the the roof in
the shed has gaps in it where you see
the stars in between and so looking up
and thinking I I got to do something I'm
gonna die if I don't get some help I'm
gonna die and so over the years Social
Services had tried to intervene a couple
times so I think well what I'll call
social services on myself and so the
when Dawn you're how old I'm 15 15 so
when Dawn came I go and this is late 15
early 16 so this is the end of the that
year beginning of the next year my
birthday is in May so it's about a that
this whole process takes almost a year
for this process thing okay so the um I
I think I got to get myself some help so
at the next day when Don came I knocked
on Mike's back door and borrowed a bus
fair and phone uh um a phone book from
his mom and called social services and
set an appointment for that afternoon
and so they brought me there and it was
Dawn when I called the appointment
wasn't until 3: or 4 in the afternoon by
the time I got there they brought my mom
in too so oh yeah we sit around at a
table big counseling table and there's
on one side there's four or five
counselors on the other side there's me
and my mom they have all sitting
together and the counselor says so what
are we here for what's your problem and
so I produce a bloody razor blade it's
box cutter style razor blade so I throw
it on the table I said that's my problem
I lift up my arm I show him the cuts I
say I feel like I'm worthless feeling
him at the bottom I feel like there's
nothing left my mom who was the most
practiced liar I've ever known got them
to believe I was just making it all up I
was just doing it for attention I just
did it to get a rise out of people it
wasn't that important and they sent me
home with
her and so we get three blocks from the
place and she turns to me with this evil
look on her face and snarls you should
do it next you should do a better job
next time I buy you the razor
blades and I'm like okay you think I'm a
monster I'll show you what a monster is
now and instead of wearing that Darkness
like a blanket I dove right into it I
just I went on what I call a a 9-month
period what I call scorched Earth where
that was where I hit my full toxicity I
was consciously going to anybody that
was nice or good or positive in my world
and offending you on purpose if there
was something that you liked I would
find that and break that if you like
something I would steal it if you if
whatever would offend you the most I'd
do that and it was to the most important
people in my world I even went to Mike's
house I stole three of the big boxes of
comic books went sold them in a comic
shop I was trying to break every bit of
positive in my world for nine solid
months I did that and then at the end of
during that period I also snuck and
Charmed my way into every family member
I could and like smoothed my way in and
got into all their picture albums got a
photo albums gathered every picture of
me into a pile and burned them so
currently there's only like five
pictures of me that exist before the age
of 15 because my my um so you you went
and established good relationships just
briefly specifically to get the pictures
because I wanted to erase my past I
wanted to annihilate my history um I was
trying to erase me and so after 9 months
of that do you think that what you were
doing look the story that you've told so
far
makes why you did what you were doing
even in this situation understandable
did you know it was wrong at that time
oh yeah you knew it was wrong well why
do you think it was wrong given that you
had all the reasons that you've
described to do it why is it because I
was hurting myself but at the time I I I
was in in that self-destructive mode I
would the Mike for instance as as an
example when I did that Mike's like dude
what the hell are you doing like I'm now
you're doing your what has been done
unjustly to you yes so you're actually
participating now you're participating
parti torturing you yes now I'm fully
given into it and I'm going to do all
the self-destruction myself I'm I'm
going to go all the way with it the the
that I I think I was told I was
worthless and a monster enough and I
told myself enough that I fully believed
it and now I'm going to make everybody
agree with me and I went to try to
offend everybody right right and so
after nine months of that I have of
personal societal
destruction I was alone completely alone
and I had been alone for over a month
and I was in that field behind Cabanita
and I've been living there for about a
month and I hadn't taken how you eating
I was stealing free samples from the
grocery store at the top of the
hill did you did you ever engage in any
criminal activity during that time apart
from that yeah I would I would I would
go I would walk up to the comic shop and
steal a whole Shelf full of comic books
walk down the street and hand them to
the first kid I
saw during that period what about what
about what about criminal Behavior minor
shoplifting I would go to the storees
steal candy bars stuff like that nothing
major just minor shoplifting okay but
during that parent I was doing it like
like egregiously and and
blatantly of self-destruction yeah I
would go to the grocery store steal an
entire shelf for the comic books and the
first kid that I would see walking down
the street I just hand him to him he you
want some Comics MH and because that it
didn't matter to me and they so yeah I
was that that kind of crime okay so now
you're out in the field you're
completely alone cuz you cut yourself
off from everyone and I wake up in the
snow and I because I had been there for
months I hadn't taken my shoes off in
weeks but I also wasn't wearing socks my
feet were just rotting off of my body I
like I said I was surviving by eating
free samples from the grocery store and
stealing whatever food I can from up
there and going dumster diving I was
trying to evade the police during school
hours by being on school campus but not
going to class I would because I had to
be otherwise You' get arrested for treny
so I'm I'm evading the police I'm and
then I wake up in the snow and it's so
cold the two block walk to get up to the
grocery store I wasn't just shaking I
was seizing I was like could barely
breathe like my body was could barely
move and I get up there and I'm looking
in the mirror and I'm trying to wash my
face off and I'm like I've got to do
something something I'm going to die if
I don't do something now I'm going to
die and so across the street from the
school I was at there was a building
that why didn't you just want to
die I don't know I don't know okay
across the street from the school that I
was nominally at was a building this
said mental health and I didn't know
what it was for I just knew that the
sign said mental health I didn't I but I
knew the last time I warned them they
brought my mom and I'm not doing that
again so I'm just going to go in
cold and so I went to the place and that
afternoon and they had me meet a young
lady she was it was a Counseling Center
they had me meet a young lady that she
was in her early 20s I think and I don't
really remember much about that
conversation cuz all I remember is the
very end where she said I'm sorry
there's nothing I can do I can't help
you and I walked out of that door and I
remember vividly standing on that porch
and it was early early night so like
that evening hour why had you not gone
for any well I guess you said why you
when you did try to go to Social
Services and always worked out badly for
you and then they brought your mom in
and that went even worse and now you
went to this mental health place and so
when I stepped out that door my brain
broke like a mirror like standing on
that step that's the spot right then and
there that my brain snapped like a
mirror and felt like shards of glass in
my brain and instantly three things
happened like one right after the other
one first thing was I found what was at
the bottom of that tsunami like I that
tsunami of pain I was living in went all
the way down to the bottom and at the
bottom there's no more waves it gets
really quiet it gets really still and
all the waves go away
because there's nothing left to lose M
like what you going to do cut my arm off
I'm die going put me in jail they're
going to feed me I don't have any more
down from here and so right then the
plans that I wanted to do crystallized
in my head I had talked them through
with those disaster groupy friends
because when we were sitting with those
disaster groupy friends instead of
talking about sports or girls or
football we talk about killing people we
talk about so if you're going to shoot
10 people how would you do it if you're
going to shoot up a school what would
you do and that was the fiction of the
group and so over the years I had
already based on why why did why did
that now you said you were at the center
of that so is that were they showboating
were they bragging it was a lot of it
was showboating and bragging and it
started off is just like like a m like
we're looking at MK murder things and
and crazy videos and stuff and and
you're toying with the dark side yeah
yeah and and I always would go further
into that dark than anybody else would
so when they were when they were looking
up so that's a status issue as well yeah
kind of and so it turn and that's how
that that's initially how those started
it was kind of like status kind of dark
yeah yeah but for me then it was plans I
knew I had talked it through I had
already knew what I was going to do I
was going to go either through the door
the um Windows into the food court the
the this was open campus area this at
the school supposed to be attending at
the school I was supposed to be
attending North High in Denver and there
was this was open campus era so they
didn't lock the doors or nothing so you
could get in and out easily could leave
the campus and go to lunch and then come
back so I knew if I went in I could go
in through the doors and go right into
the food court and kill everybody in the
food court and what were how are you
going to do that well so the two let me
that portion of it so the two the two
plans was either either the food court
there or the Mall food court and it both
both the same things neither one of
those spots were soft targets the school
had uniformed our police officers
station in at all times and the mall had
a police station a couple hour down from
the food court the plan was to cause as
much damage as possible and die while
doing it yeah and but that wasn't really
the goal of my attack the goal of my
attack was to cause my parents to deal
with making me I wanted to have them
deal with the ramifications of creating
me so I wanted to cause as much damage
as possible as visibly as possible diew
doing it so then they had to deal with
creating a monster you think that would
have made any difference I don't I don't
know but that was the goal at the time I
I I that that was what was in my head at
the time and and so and I knew it a form
of Revenge yeah but I didn't but but I
felt that attacking them would have been
useless that what they're going to hurt
for one day and that's going to be
nothing they've never faced
accountability for anything they've ever
done and they did me so now they have to
face up with making me and that was that
was the goal of that and I knew what to
I knew where to get a gun because this
was boys in the hood ERA this was late
90s so the gang bangers were all over
and they would bring guns into school
and Flash them in in the school because
it was before the age of metal detectors
so they would just flash handguns and
they bought and sold drugs for my family
so they knew me they knew they knew I
was living in the field they they would
regularly Buy drugs from my family and
so I went up to him like Hey can you get
me a gun hopefully one that shoots a lot
of bullets yeah sure get me an ounce of
weed and that these days that's walking
down to a a store and getting it back
then that's like 300 bucks worth of
ballistic narcotics but for me that was
easy they knew my parents were drug
dealers I just went to my family's house
stole it out of a druggies pant sleeping
on my brother's bedroom floor like he
had three ounces in his pocket I just
took one out of his pocket took it and
so did you get a gun I did I didn't get
a gun I I went and gave him the weed I
was set to get the gun he told me 3 days
with in 3 days time I was going to have
the gun and in that 3-day time that's
when I was set the incident I got the
gun I was going to cause the attack if
it was daytime go to the school night
time go to the mall that was the only
how detailed had your plans been I knew
exactly what door I was going to go into
and what I was going to do and where how
much time do you suppose you spent
setting up those plans
oh so that's a that's a two-sided
question the plan itself crystallized
instantly but I had sent months planning
that because we talked about it how much
time do you suppose you spent with your
guys oh oh weeks and weeks that so how
many hours at least 30 or 40 okay okay
yeah lot long times of PL of just of
just that dark conversation of planning
it that's fantasizing and planning and
in that you're working through the and
and I I didn't realize it then I don't
think they realize it then but we were
working through the ins and outs and the
the problems with it and what's going to
work and what's not going to work and so
yeah by the time it all happened I had
the plan and it came out well that's
that's the danger of practicing
something yeah and so I I knew right
then and so in that three-day time I
didn't think about it then but looking
back I think I was saying goodbye okay
because I I didn't know that was what I
was doing then but I was going to people
in a much more peaceful way and like
saying thank you and went to my
ex-girlfriend and said thank you for
letting me sleep on the gravel outside
your window and I was going just saying
sorry for things and I was I think I was
saying goodbye mhm and at the end of
that I went to Mike's house and when I
went to Mike's house I knocked on his
door and he opened it and I was in tears
and I was just crying and he brought me
in and he never asked what I was there
for he never asked what it was about he
knew intimately the hell I had been
living in it was his bedroom that I was
in there when I was with the cuts on my
arms and he saw the pain from my family
he knew intimately the hell I was in but
he didn't ask he just brought me in and
sat me down and kept on telling me over
and over again you're a good kid in a
world that's what he kept on saying
to me and he sat me down and he gave me
some food and we watched a movie and he
acted like that nine months of
Destruction never
happened and it wasn't hanging out with
a friend that saved my life that wasn't
what did it it was that when I knocked
on his door I felt like I was a walking
ball of nothing I was just there to
close off my life and write the last
line and say thank you goodbye I'm done
turn the lights off I'm out and so I
thought that I was just
a nothing waiting to explode and what he
did I think was he put the tiny granular
bits of being a person back on the
bottom shelf of my life like it was why
was he able to do that do you think what
is it about
Mike he if you asked him what he did he
just said he just did what a friend
supposed to
do yeah but he was the only person that
you found who did that for you and and I
I don't know what it is but he's the
only one that no matter what happened he
never treat me like I was anything but
an equal he never looked at me like I
was broken he never looked at me like I
was a project he looked at me like I was
a kid in pain and so he would talk to me
about it and he would we would he we
would he never looked down on me we
would have deep discussions he was going
to high school for philosophy and going
to college and all this stuff yeah I was
a Dropout and I was living in this crime
infested hell hole and he never once
acted like I wasn't anything but a buddy
that deserved respect to talk to the
holidays are rapidly approaching but we
can find peace and calm in the craziness
of the season with hallow the number one
Christian Prayer app in the world
immerse yourself in Christmas in Advent
prayers meditations and peaceful
Christmas music hallow also offers an
extensive library of Bible reading plans
accompanied by insightful Reflections
and audio guided meditations whether
you're a seasoned Bible reader or just
starting your journey Hall provides a
platform for you to engage with
scripture like never before a great
place to start is with father Mike
schmitz's Bible in a year in which he
offers brief daily readings and
Reflections available on the Hallow app
the Hallow app also helps you connect
with a community of like-minded
individuals sharing experiences insights
and encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth this Christmas join
Hallow's Christmas prayer challenge
Advent with CS Lewis for the 25 days
leading up to Christmas you can focus on
the real reason for the season with
prayer meditation and Christmas music on
hallow download the app for free at
hall.com Jordan for 3 months free that's
hall.com
Jordan
and it was the only part of my life that
Mike have other friends yeah yeah Mike
had a big Social Circle and that's going
to tie into the next part of the story
so the so what I not what he did with
that it wasn't just that I could like
have a meal it was that I can enjoy food
now MH like I can be reminded of the
base human things and for me it was
absolutely cathartic it was like like
rolling the clock back on my Humanity
like so you you had abandoned any sense
of value in
totally I he was uning to let that go
unwilling unwilling to let it go and and
not even unwilling to let it go it was
that he didn't even see that it was
leaving MH it was like like that's a
weird dynamic it wasn't that he didn't
let me slide off the cliff so he didn't
even see that I was on a cliff like or
didn't even treat me like I was on a
cliff and that was extremely powerful to
be seen when you feel fundamentally
invisible like I would walk around and
ask my classmates do you remember me
when I leave the room but I'm gone do
you remember that I was here cuz I
thought and you'd just been ignored by
the mental health clinic too yeah I felt
completely invisible I felt alone and
and nothing and to be seen and validated
in in the most normal ways just like
like it was just a regular Tuesday MH
and to me I was on the precipice of a
life
altering
Madness and it was just a
Tuesday and it it fundamentally changed
my life and I didn't leave his house for
a week and everyone went and got the gun
and now was Mike still living with his
parents so why were you allowed to stay
there I think he went and talked to him
I don't know why okay I did never ask
him I did I never even saw his parents
that week uhhuh I I I just went and
basically stayed in his bedroom I think
he just went and talked to him I I I
think he just was like hey Aaron really
needs this and so yeah he's staying in
my bedroom so I can get in trouble for
it if you want to but he's there cuz by
by that point that's kind of the
attitude that he had he had had it with
his with his friends group he went to
art school and so he had a bunch of art
friends and so they were really preppy
and yepy and so well to do and not all
of them looked not all of them were very
uh um as charitable as Mike was to
someone like me and so there were friend
groups where they were like well Aaron
needs to go he smells and Mike would
stand up in the middle of him like no
dude if you're saying needs to go you go
ahead and bounce right now cuz he's not
going anywhere and so that kind of
validation and belonging it was it
fundamentally changed me to my core and
but and during that week during that
week it it it changed me well that's the
start it's it's it's important to note
that it's not like it's a magic light
switch it's not like ding everything's
better and it's all fixed this was a
process and this was the start of the
process so what he did was give me a
frame shift he let me change my
perspective a bit it it the clock rolled
back I my it was like I said instead of
washing that tsunami and going through
crazy and slashing around could set my
feet down for the first time so he
reminded you that you weren't rot to
that I wasn't rot to my core and so I
could be for a little while
and so that and he also talked to one of
his friends and let me stay with one of
his friends for a while so was able to
get a house a sleeping Arrangement and
reassess and shift my frame of reference
just a bit enough to take a breath right
right and reestablish with my personhood
but the chaos at home was still the same
the abuse at home was still the same the
violence all there was still the same
the self-hatred was still the same that
hell was still there but I was able to
step back off that edge and take a
breath but now we're going to fast
forward three years okay cuz that was
between 15 and 16 now to go to the night
of my 19th birthday okay night of my
19th birthday I was planning on
committing suicide I the Depression had
so now you dropped you dropped the
school shooting dropped the school
shooting dropped the school shooting it
had went it had went from outward anger
to because almost instantly when Mike
did that I felt ashamed and remorseful
almost instantly when when when that
reestablishment of my Humanity hit the
the remorse and the shame of what I had
planned was so that's so interesting one
of the things that you're claiming is
that you would have only been able to go
through with what you had planned if you
had in fact successfully severed every
tie you had right you would have had to
have been genuinely alone and alienated
and Mike reminded you that you weren't
so I I thought that I was right yeah
yeah but Mike reminded me that I wasn't
with that right and sort of despite your
best efforts right cuz you'd spent you
said eight months trying to alienate
mons yeah yeah but despite all my best
efforts and despite massive effort on my
part that he he just wouldn't let go and
that's love very much so here's here's a
great example of that love that's why I
like telling this part of the story so n
my 19th birthday I was planning on
committing suicide and I was going to do
it by overdose I had gotten a bunch of
LSD off the streets stolen a bunch of
pills from cocaine from my mom I had
copious amounts of drugs way more than
we're going to need to do the job and
because my depression had spun up and I
was but I was inward I was I wasn't
outward aggress anymore it was just I
was ashamed and depressed I just wanted
to end it tired dealing with this
anymore but I had interventions in the
past Mike K be like dude you're
depressed we need to stop it I didn't
want any of that so I was trying to act
as normal as possible trying to act like
they nothing was wrong in my day so I
went to Mike's house and Mike's a very
social guy he has a Social Circle of his
own and one of this group friends is a
girl named Amber okay and Amber was
really friendly with me she was always
really nice to me but she was his
contact she was definitely his friend
and but we would go over to her house
every now and then watch a movie listen
to music whatever and so he's like hey
we're going to kick it at Amber today
like great that's sounds like a great
last day going to spend it with two of
my favorite people and then go back to
the field by costanita and end my life
that was the plan and so I get there and
that wasn't it at all I actually walked
into a surprise birthday party for me
and I walked into about 14 people saying
happy happy birthday and Amber had baked
a blueberry peach pie and I walked past
him and dropped on my drugs in the
toilet that was the last time I ever
tried to kill myself and that's what
really set me on my path and here's
where the love portion comes in because
when we left Mike's house there was no
birthday party Mike called the head to
Amber's house and said hey Amber I'm
taking over there and this his birthday
today and Amber was having a get
together she had already had a bunch of
people over she had already baked the
pie and she's like hey Aaron's coming
over and it's his birthday let's make it
a birthday party for him so they all got
together and made a bunch of decorations
and stuff and threw up a quick birthday
party I walked into a fundamentally
life-changing thing that changed my
opinion of myself to my core that my put
friend put up in five minutes of being
nice to another
friend so yeah just a simple act of
kindness nothing the the the people who
tried to be not so simple not so man but
but but real yeah and fundamental and
genuine genuinely thoughtful genuinely
thoughtful and that it it changed me
that that's that's what really started
me on the path to that was the time when
I reassessed and right after that I I
did some serious soul searching about is
this me uhhuh or is this not me and had
deep conversation with Mike and Amber
and other friends about how no dude this
isn't me this is I will live through
hell and yeah I Mal adapted to it I made
some really bad decisions and I made
some really toxic choices but I don't
have to stay there I can move out of
this hell now and I can keep going and I
can let them live their hell on that
side well now you're old enough too cuz
you're 19 at that point and at that
point Mike actually Saved My Life One
More Time by he moved me out to Kansas
City the final clip that cut the family
hooks out of me was he went to college
in Kansas City and moved me out there
for a summer I got to go live with him
out in KC and I was I'm from Denver so
got to go spend a summer out away from
my family that did two things they gave
me the confidence that I could do
something on my own wouldn't get a job
pay bills pay rent be stable it also
pissed my family off when I got back how
dare you leave how dare you think you're
better than us how dare you how dare you
have a life how dare you think you can
exist without us and so that was where I
was able to be like all right fine dude
they're they're attacking me for making
myself better yeah this isn't me yeah
this is them yeah and so that's where I
finally made that flip and right about
that same time I started on the the real
process of my recovery which I call
acknowledgement so I was about 19 years
old and I still again mom still has her
hooks on me at the time I was working
with her at a Veterans of forign Wars
bar and so she um we it was right
shortly after I had kind of started to
Ser a contact and I'm in this process
but I was working there so she was
running the bar I was a bartender there
and it was a Veterans of Foreign Wars
bar so veterans go in there started
drinking like morning I was 19 years old
okay so and the uh my aunt aunt is on
the other side of the bar and it's a
bunch of people drinking whole bu busy
night and she's on the other side of the
bar and she's one of the people who had
tried to molest me when I was younger
dug through the carpet for crack rock
tried to kill herself a couple times in
front of me toxic toxic person and she's
on the other side of the bar and she's
just off handly talking I don't even
hear the conversation they're having all
I hear is are say Oh Aaron you know you
love me and I stopped and said no I
don't and I didn't mean to say that I it
just came out I said no I don't and she
said what I said no I don't actually
love you tried to kill yourself in front
of me you tried to molest me and I don't
actually love you I'm done and she
started screaming she blew up and had a
big old screaming fit and to me it was
like white noise I didn't hear any of it
it turned into the static because it was
like an anvil jumped off of my chest
like instantly just instant release and
I felt so good afterwards that I just
walked out like oh my God I just I just
did that uhuh and it it was Declaration
Freedom yeah and so that started a
process where I did that exact thing to
everybody in my life that abused me I
went in a process of acknowledgement and
I'm I made sure it was purposeful very
purposeful that it wasn't retaliatory I
didn't go to anybody and say you did
this and you need to pay for it I went
to him and said this is our F our
relationship has fundamentally changed I
don't actually love you and I'm done and
I walked away and that had such a
cathartic effect on me how did you know
that it shouldn't be retaliatory I just
felt it in my core that it shouldn't be
because I felt if it was retaliatory
that just continues the argument it
engages and continues the contest you're
still hooked it's still hooked and it
still continues to back and forth and
it's still the toxicity we're going come
back with well you did this I don't care
maybe that's why you turn the other
cheek yeah this isn't about retaliation
this isn't about me getting something
back cuz you hurt me you hurt me and I'm
dealing with it right and I'm dealing
with it by being done with it yeah I'm
dealing with it I'm done with it and I'm
going to walk away and I'm going to stop
having that hurt and and what sort of
response did you get from some of them
screened and some of them yelled and
some of them begged me to stay and I
didn't care none of it mattered to me I
just made sure that I said it why did
you why do you think you were able to
not be manipulated into feeling
guilty I think because by that point I
had burned out the ability to get
embarrassed or ashamed about anything I
had burned out the and I had burned out
the ability for any of those family
members judgment to hurt me anymore yeah
well and as you said too You' be down in
Kansas City and you had that break where
you could take care of yourself and have
a life and and that gave me a breath and
and light on that to see it showing a
bright light on that toxicity to see
that that was its own sense of hell like
it's it's their insults cause other
people to insult them back cause a fight
to happen it's just a violent Circle
that just spins around and around and if
I engage in that at all I get sucked
into it yeah but looking at it it looks
really stupid so the more I can step
back and look at it the easier it got
right right and so your life it was it
was very important to me to to not have
it be retaliatory and to make sure that
it was just get it out of me and when
every time I did it was like a step it
was it was like flying it was like like
Elation yeah just just pure Elation that
I was able to do it and now today I can
confidently say that I never sit and
have the regret that oh my God I wish
this person knew how I felt uhuh they
all know they all know they all know I'm
fine with telling them again so you
started to get your life together fairly
seriously at about 19 at about 19 that's
when I started well kind of emotionally
I started to get myself better and I
started to reassess that I that I can do
it get myself some stability and drop a
lot of that toxic um affectation did you
go back to Kansas City I did not I I
actually came back to Colorado and and
got but it living by myself and living
and got my own apartment Mike was
helping me and got my own job okay out
of that family hook and what job did you
get I was actually let's see right
around then I was working at a Starbucks
in Barnes & Noble downtown Denver so I
was just working at a coffee shop
service jobs and did you learn to do a
good job yeah yeah I I've always been
every job I go they always want me to be
manager every every first job I ever had
I became assistant manager you said that
you didn't do your assignments and so
forth at school so how did how was it
that you were able to do a good job when
you got a job the because when I when my
the assignments I just never found them
to be important for me I engage with
things that I think are important so you
felt it was important felt it was and
important to do a good job and
beneficial to do a good job this the
assignments of the school I felt were
wrote busy work the if I if I know the
subject for instance English class the
reason why I always went to English
class was because the I had a teacher
that I had gotten kicked out of the
advanced placement English class for
correcting the teacher on Shakespeare I
he I I first day of class I corrected
him on Shakespeare I had happened to be
in my acid field parties with my dis
friends we were acting out the plays of
Shakespeare at night that's what we
would do we had the complete works of
Shakespeare we were got the midsummer
night stream and just pick a character
and go through the play that's what we
would do trip and acid 16-year-old and
so I went to school and my teacher was
teaching Shakespeare first day and he
was getting it wrong and it happened to
me in summer Night's Dream and so I
corrected him and the teacher does that
thing you see in the TV like well Mr
Stark would you like to get up and teach
the class like yeah so I stood up and
started holding court and so I started
talking about it and he pulled me out of
the class opened up the opened up the
door class everybody could see still me
in front of the class started berading
me and screaming at me don't you ever
contradict me like that how dare you
confront me in front of class like that
don't you ever do that get out of here
kick me out of this class sent me down
to remedial English so I got kicked out
of the class where I'm correcting my
Shakespeare go into the class where
they're teaching sentence structure and
punctuation and I'm like I go to the
teacher I'm like you didn't find that
particularly motivated no not really I
went to the teacher I'm like hey can I I
know this can I do this can I get your
final because I know this stuff I do I I
write and I read I'm really good at this
like you can do that like please just
let me prove it and so she did she gave
me the final same teacher same te no
different teacher oh different remedial
English I see go down to remedial
English her medal English teacher is a
lady and she's like can you do it I'm
like yeah sure so I take her final i ace
the final for imal English got a 100%
And so from then on I was her deao class
assistant so even though I never went to
class and even though I was only there
once every 3 weeks when I was there I
didn't have to do the assignments I
could just walk around and help
everybody else with their assignments
and on book report day I I didn't have
to read the book If I could walk up to
her and explain what the book was if I
go to her and tell her the story and
tell her what happened to the book and
explain that I know what it is I didn't
have to write the report and so she was
a real teacher she was a real teacher
and she saw me as for being smart and so
I would even though it was remedial
English I went to that class every day
all the every day I could every day I
could get to that class I could go to
that class cuz that was one little hour
where I felt valued and and like I
belonged right right yeah well part of
the story that you were telling has that
motive in it is that what you needed and
unsurprisingly given the structure of
your family and the fact that you were
moving constantly and that you were
generally friendless was a sense of
genuine belonging and you had that to
some degree with your with your group of
of uh miscreant but it was based on
something that was very bad at its core
Mike you had a you had an actual
relationship an actual relationship yeah
and with Mike I valued it so much that I
memorized his phone number and every
time I moved out of state I had I had he
was my home base yeah so I I like I
every other attachment could disappear
and but Mike was always right always
there right okay so I I'm going to we
got to close this up unfortunately
because I'd like to find out you know
what happened later in your life too cuz
you you got married and you have kids
and like you have a life and and yeah so
we're gonna well we can fast forward to
when I came out with my story well I
want to ask you a specific question sure
if if you don't mind well there's going
to be people who are watching this and
listening to it who are feeling both
desperate and they probably have the
reasons for it and who are feeling not
only desperate but resentful and
vengeful mhm right and who are toying
with those sorts of dark ideas that you
toyed with and so if you could say
something to them other than everything
that you've just said is there anything
specific you would say that you know
that would be helpful to someone who is
tempted by that those darkest of
motivations what I tell my own kids all
the time is that the only thing constant
in life is change that the only thing
that's absolutely certain is that
tomorrow's going to be different than
today that it might not be better and it
might not be worse but it is going to be
different and so we can we have choices
with that we can either resist that
change and get worn down like the rocks
on the beach and turn into sand and just
get annihilated or we can adapt with
those changes and move like the water
itself and the more we can be that
change and realize that the path that we
are carrying and the damage and the
destruction that we are that we have
experienced is not us it's just luggage
that we're carrying around with us it's
just the baggage that we carry that the
more we can maybe part of not accept
that damning Judgment of yourself and
others as find when when you when you
tell yourself that you're worthless
enough and that you hate yourself and
everybody hurs you too that's your brain
lying to you that's your brain lying to
you you are in fact good enough you woke
up good enough today and it's okay that
you messed up and it's okay that you
were wrong and it's okay that you got if
your Future's okay and it's okay to be
okay mhm it's okay to be good sometimes
that's not a bad thing it's okay to feel
well that's a weird thing to conclude if
you have for example bargained to accept
a very low social status because you've
already in some ways made a contract
with yourself that you're going to be an
outsider you're going to be unpopular
and that you are worthless and one and
one thing that happens when you
internalize that so much is that it gets
to be repellent to any positivity like
like someone were to come up and say oh
you're really a good person well you
don't really know me then if you see me
then you'd see the Monster cuz I'm not
really a good person yeah well it also
violates the contract it does it does
because we've established now that I'm
the loow p and and the only way that
I've seen for for an outside source to
be able to combat that is with
consistency and the only way I've by by
being the one that doesn't break when
the waves crash against you to to not to
be a mic to not to not give up when the
stuff gets hard but when when you're in
that dark to realize that just keep
going so why do you think liked you so
much because I was smart because he he
always says it it was because of the
deep conversations because he could
could sit and talk for hours and never
be bored we can sit valued that in you
really valued that in me and and that I
was always that I would give everything
of myself for my friends even from back
then like if I had it I didn't value my
stuff so if I had something you needed
it I'm fine with giving it to you and I
would give Mike the shirt off my back I
tell him today dude I'd give you the
skin off my back if you ever have a need
so you were also a friend to Mike yeah
and and and it was intellectual respect
like the meeting meeting of peers mhm
mhm yeah all right well I'm going to
close this up I think that's a very good
place to end thank you for walking us
through that one of the things I did
notice from a clinical perspective by
the way is that you showed very little
emotion negative emotion when you were
describing what happened to you in your
past and there's there's two possible
explanations for that when you see it
and one is that a person has hurt so bad
that the emotion has just they're just
flat but the other possibility is that
the events have been put in their proper
place and stripped of their emotional
significance and transcend it so that
they're no longer relevant and that
looks to me like what you've managed and
congratulations on that because thank
you very much given what you went
through that's a ma major moral
achievement and the fact that you were
able to deal with that and to stop it
from being transmitted to your children
is a that's work of incalculable
significance yeah today my kids have all
gone to the same Middle School atary
school and high school they've all gone
they they've never been evicted they've
never had their mom beating their dad
and their dad beating their mom none of
that I say I use what happened to me
growing up as exact examples of how to
parent my children I just isn't it
interesting you know that and this is a
real mystery about human beings too is
that like really in some fundamental
sense all you had were bad examples now
it's not exactly true because you had
your brother and had Mike and you had
some friendships and so you could see
how reasonable and positive Human
Relationships were were were uh
structured but anyone listening to the
story that you relay would say well you
have every reason to not know how to be
a good husband and a good father and yet
despite all that and despite the
determinism of a
multigenerational family of pathology on
both sides you were able to step away
from it and establish something positive
in the confines of your own life and I
do it specifically by using what
happened to me as a kid like exact
examples of the parenting that I went
through and just do the opposite right
right well well it's so interesting
because like if you're bullied there are
two things you can learn from that or at
least two things one is how to bully and
the other is that you should never bully
right and it's the same lesson there's
something about the manner in which the
lesson is received that determines the
consequences it's not a deterministic
course in that like well we do know that
most people and this is actually the
truth almost all people who abuse as
adults were abused as children but most
people who were abused as children don't
abuse as adults y right right right so
and and that I so now I I think that I
won because today my kids are happy and
healthy and H and and friendly and yeah
that's a deal my 12-year-old when
there's a new kid in her class the
teacher puts the new kid next to her
because she's the class Ambassador so
she's she's the welcomer for the class
right so yeah you said that I I don't
get aemotion with that that's a good one
that's a good way to end man well
congratulations on that sir thank you
sir that's a major accomplishment and
say hi to your 12-year-old thank you I
will you bet you bet all right everyone
thank you very much for watching and
listening today your time and attention
is uh always much appreciated thank you
to the dailywire plus people for
facilitating this live conversation
we're going to be doing a bunch of them
over the next couple of months to the
film crew here here in Scottsdale um
thank you for well setting this up and
making it run so professionally um and
we'll we'll see you all very soon thank
you for having me that was great yeah
appreciate it thank
[Music]
you